so just a reminder in terms of where we
are right now in the course we are
returning to a topic that we were
discussing in the week number five i
believe it was economic activity broadly
construed and relationship between faith
and economy after foray into
relationship between or the place of the
person of faith within the context of
globalized world today how to bring to
bear faith convictions on the world
affairs and then two sessions on couplet
of religion and violence and religion
and reconciliation we're turning back to
faith and business this time
concentrating not so much on the large
macro picture but on an individual
corporation and to introduce this
session we will have as last time also
Joel pedal me see you all again so um so
in week six right we focused on the
macro level considerations in terms of
the relationship between economy on the
on the one hand and and spirituality and
faith based attitudes on the other
looking in particular at the at the
China case you know here we have as you
know from the conversations you've
already had this week around Cadbury
voice of Iraq that that the focus is now
very much on the organization and how
and and whether or not and what are the
what are the ways in which values social
commitments can be or should be
implemented at the level of the
organization I'll begin by making
essentially sort of six observations to
hopefully set the stage for our visitors
today
I and then and then we'll just go from
there so so observation number one being
sort of a sociologist and empirical
sociologist at that I'm and begin just
with kind of the empirical fact may have
been discussed in some of your sessions
while there's a lot of talk about
whether or not there's a positive
empirical relationship between being
socially responsible as a corporation
and profitability there is absolutely no
evidence that the scholars at the
leading institutions would regard as
compelling on this point and and and and
there and there are so many counter
examples that are out there that it that
just is an empirical fact that seems a
very hard one to sustain so the argument
that corporations will be or should be
socially responsible just because it is
profitable for them to do so is
difficult to sustain now if it turns out
that you find yourself in a cocktail
party conversation with somebody who
insists that the evidence is there
usually when the evidence is it's
evidence in a cross-section and and
causality is very hard to determine if
for example somebody told you that very
profitable corporations are likely to
give better healthcare benefits to their
workers than unprofitable corporations
you'd have no problem concluding that
you know maybe the causality is reversed
and if you're very profitable you can
afford to give good health care benefits
and if you're not profitable than you
can't that's that's always a pretty
strong counter for any of the any of the
empirical relationships have been
observed so that's point number one but
so so given that there's there's no kind
of conclusive evidence on the empirical
relationship there obviously is evidence
that leaders of for-profit corporations
can be values based in their actions
without it necessarily coming at the
expense of shareholders especially if
those values are a motivation for their
employees right so the fact that there's
not a relationship in general doesn't
mean that
individual leader of an organization can
decide there's some values I'm going to
be committed to and i am going to work
to be smarter and work harder and in
particular can draw employees who may be
motivated by the particular set of
values i'm going to drive forward now
the fact that it may apply for one firm
in an industry right so it doesn't
necessarily mean it could apply for all
of them right because you can get
selection effects in the beginning right
if you are the best if you're the best
chocolate manufacturer and quart of
controlling your supply chain you draw
employees from the others because they
all want to work for you there's a limit
probably to the number of firms that
that would apply to in the industry now
and and now having said that you know
even when it's a motivation for
employees that can summits come at some
cost which is and if you were taking
strictly the perspective of the
shareholders it would come at the font
which is even if you get these motivated
employees who are willing to accept
lower pay because they're getting to
wake up every morning and work for a
company that's consistent with their
values it's also the case that then the
company's brand usually can be held
hostage by NGOs in ways that then could
be problematic for the shareholders nike
is a good example here on this you know
the if you talk to those NGOs who were
most concerned about nike supply chain
practices most of them i think would
having written cases on this at the time
most of them would admitted that nike
was not necessarily the worst offender
it just had the best brand and in
particular it had employees who they
work for nike because they got to go
tell their friends I work for Nike and
they were and they and they consume that
and and phil knight who I interviewed as
part of this case series I did at night
he said you know the thing that hurt the
hardest was not that consumers were
necessarily buying less shoes it was
that our employees motivation was
fundamentally tarnished that you know
from working for for a company that was
associated with sort of health and sport
and you know and and kind of this
rebellious
anti-establishment quality we be can't
we started to look like we were a
tobacco company right I mean it was it
was essentially what he said so I you
know so so so if it's possible right i
mean if there are examples that we can
point to of organizations where the
leaders of their organizations have have
run them in a way that they can they can
sort of drive values that are considered
there's still an implementation question
and one of the things we've got
Christine Bader here in and I'll give
Christina fuller introduction in a
second but she's she's been working at
BP and I know I've got the notes right
here since but she's been in chart for a
number of years but she's been in charge
of policy development at BP since 2004
and and and was at BP really at the time
that John Brown was very much trying to
implement a set of values that were that
he believed in and and and interesting
we'll talk about that so that's the
second point right is you know leaders
can be value-based it can be hard it
doesn't necessarily resolve in more
profits but there's still the
implementation question to the third and
just to tie this to the readings the
standards that you've got you know some
of the readings you have basically are
providing ethical standards that we can
sort of think about so there's the
reading by sin there was the reading by
cone the ethical framework the I guess I
would say two things about these
frameworks as a practical matter right
and you must have seen this in the
Cadbury case they don't provide a huge
amount of guidance right I mean for
questions like how much due diligence
should you be doing with respect to your
supply chain they don't provide question
a lot of guidance for questions on you
know the living wage and exactly what
should the living wage be or doing
business and countries that allow
discrimination on the basis of gender
right i mean when you get to almost any
very specific question having said that
what the frameworks do is they create a
vernacular they create a language and
and to the degree to which it's it is
it's a it's a coke
he civ set of ideas underlying the
framework they potentially also they
provide not just the language but a
framework for a conversation now that
can take place between businesses NGOs
government that that any of those
constituencies and the and the broader
populace as well can use for thinking
about you know either what laws should
be in place what corporations should be
doing the question is is given a
framework how does it get enough moral
authority to actually be invoked by
enough people or enough institutions to
have an impact in the world right I mean
it certainly helped when send won the
Nobel Prize you know that that that kind
of adds to your moral authority right
the other thing that Christine has been
has been has been working on is with the
human Ron ruggy at the UN around
developing sort of a standard there
you've got the UN's sort of seal of
approval is potentially something else
that would enable this framework for the
conversation but I think in no case and
you certainly saw in the readings is
there going to be a lot of guidance that
you can sort of apply to the decision
tree analysis it's like okay if these
are the rights you believe in there for
this is how much resources you should
devote to your supply chain so so you've
seen some normative frameworks Christine
will talk about others and then then
sort of the fifth point that I guess I
would make is you know even if
corporations care only about narrow
profit maximization they need to
understand the impact the globalization
has on the identities of individuals
because of the potential backlash
against those corporations I mean that's
essentially the point of the Freedman
reading right that the drive of
globalization associated with the Lexus
right provokes identity-based defense
mechanisms be one way to sort of
articulate it that are associated in
that particular story with the olive
tree and so even as sort of a pragmatic
consideration sort of understanding that
sociological dynamic is important and
and with that i think i can i realize i
said i was going to do six points i
think i'm going to save one so I'll so
I'll turn it over to Tim to talk about
you know this you know essentially just
the basic question of what can we and
should we be able to expect of
corporations because the remarks I've
been giving so far today have said
something about what leaders as
individuals can do have said about what
frameworks can do to create a context
for a large number of constituencies but
at least to this point I haven't said
anything about what you know we can and
should expect from corporations
independently of individuals and that's
the point that obviously the freedmen
reading sort of raises probably more
salient Lee than any of the rest but Tim
we'll take it from there so that that
actually made it a lot simpler so the
answer is nothing right I'm gonna leave
gonna write this down though first
nothing that helped a lot so professor
wolf made me this time write down what I
was going to say so that he could censor
censor it so that it would be available
for the video tape for future
generations so it made him write down
nothing thought if he thought I was
gonna go to sleep at eleven o'clock at
night but I didn't so there's another
version
only slightly more provocative so I have
the power of shopping go birding so I'm
allowed to have a preamble and then I
guess he's going to tell me how how
deeply wrong i am but with my now edited
preamble I'd say that I am really
interested in the discussion about how
to make the world a better place but
what I'm not interested in and I think
it's an important discussion now because
the world's a shambles you know on
almost every level and I am staggered by
every day a new revelation I just we
just were looking at the market general
electric's at fourteen dollars a share
Apple is now at twelve it was at 22 when
we first looked on its way to zero
however as interested as I am in that
discussion all right for me discussion
about responsible behavior to be
valuable has to be two really simple
preconditions one it has to really talk
about the difficult issues not the mushy
simple issues like you know do we do we
want to have human slavery it's got to
talk about the difficult really gnarly
issues that you know will face all of
you every day if you're awake enough to
realize it and secondly it's got to have
that discussion has to be done with I
think precision and rigor and clarity
and that sounds trivial but as I've read
through much of the course material and
had lots of these discussions I find
that the discussion really meets those
two simple tests so professor wolf is
forbidden me to wander off into the
quagmire of the really basic questions
of meta ethics or political legitimacy
but I couldn't I couldn't come and sit
here without warning you that much of
this debate
about normative questions glosses over
the really profound and controversial
issues of this kind so for instance I
like to know before we're done what what
Professor wolf thinks Miller can't would
say about a pyramid of values which I
find as woolly and mushy a concept is as
they come so what that will will wait
with bated breath for that so in my
allocated time I'd like to introduce in
my few minutes the ideas in hunger the
the allegory from Plato the Milton
Friedman I didn't bother with Thomas
Friedman the Milton Friedman Dunning in
Greenspan and let me just start with
Unger hunger uses to what i think are
incredibly powerful examples to
highlight the tension in making every
day individual normative decisions Unger
obviously has a much bigger project but
I'm forbidden to talk about that one but
the examples are powerful as is the
simplicity of his message is message in
my reading is that making normative
decisions is really hard making them on
behalf of other people is even harder so
let me read you on the chance that you
didn't already read the to hunger singer
I think singer with was the inspiration
for the shallow pond the shallow pond
the path from the library you're at your
University of the humanities lecture
hall passes a shallow ornamental pond on
your way to give a lecture you notice
that a small child is falling in and is
in danger of drowning if you weighed in
and pull the child out it will mean
getting your clothes money and either
canceling your lecture delaying it until
you can find something clean it right
aware if you pass by the child then
while you you'll give your lecture on
time the child will die straightaway you
pass by and as expected the child dies
then his brackets this example with the
UNICEF envelope in your mailbox there
something from UNICEF after reading it
thoroughly you correctly believe that
unless you send in a check for a hundred
dollars and instead of each child living
many more years over
30 more children will die soon but you
throw the material in the trash basket
including the convenient return out I
always like that including the
convenient return envelope provided you
send nothing instead of living many
years over 30 more children soon die and
because you didn't send the request at
hundred dollars so hunger hunger spends
a lot of this book living high and
letting died about how similar these
dilemmas are that they're not actually
as ridiculously opposite as they seem
and I think for me that is a really
emblematic of how really difficult if
you think hard about the moral dilemmas
that you face every day we talked about
giving two thousand dollars to Johnny
Isakson it was an unbelievably difficult
calculation to conclude that that was
the right thing to do and these these
things happen every day and and so I
guess the message of hunger for me is
that these aren't really just
hypothetical exaggerations for a really
fascinating philosophical debate about
meta ethics or other things that I'm not
allowed to talk about it's really a
great example that every day we make
decisions to whether we should save
General Motors or intervene in Darfur or
whether we should reduce capital gains
taxes or cure ALS so making these kind
of choices on your own bat is hard
enough making them on behalf of others
whether it's governments or corporations
is really really hard now I thought I
turned quickly to what I'm supposed to
talk about and that is how the real
world works and I have taken this
example of the ring of guy geez out of
its proper context plato proves i'm sure
decisively in the dialogue that it's
best to be virtuous and i guess i I'm
sure he's right I could never quite
figure it out but I'm sure it's right
but for me there's this is this allegory
and leaving it where where we've left it
is is good enough to make a point about
a concept that I find
really troublesome and that is the the
point the concept of enlightened
self-interest seems to me that
enlightenment has no hold over
self-interest as far as I can tell
they're basically two accounts of
enlightened self-interest one argument
claims that you'll be in the long run
better off if you follow the enlightened
path and I guess I'm not supposed to say
the story about Lady astron Winston
Churchill so I won't but but it ends by
Winston Churchill just haggling saying
that they're just haggling over price
and i'll let you could figure the rest
of it out so the this argument about
enlightened self-interest to me a
circular and in fact it's just
self-interested with the great PR
campaign the second case is a slightly
better one and that is the argument that
the world would be better off if we
behave in a liteon way and will somehow
indirectly benefit better off as well
there's still problems with this first
either we are willing to be less
well-off and this seems to conflict with
the notion of self-interest or not or it
requires one of these great empirical
studies that I think is probably you
know impossible to do that in some
remote way we're going to all be better
off because the world's a better place
if we you know if we fill the UNICEF
envelope way far away in in Sudan 300
children live that somehow or other will
be better off seems to me to be to be
untenable so and we take guy geez the
best thing to be obviously is to be
completely self interested but invisible
so that you can you know steal and
pillage lying you know cheat but still
be perceived as virtuous because of your
generosity when you're no longer
invisible that's a thing to be greedy
and selfish but to be perceived as
generous and virtuous must on the self
interest calculator be
the coast and Nirvana so these I think
these things are are mushy notions
enlightened self-interest and then when
you go one step further and try to lodge
the idea of responsibility in a
corporation and the idea now of
corporate social responsibility I guess
I could say really simply I just agree
with Milton Friedman and this may be the
only thing I've ever agreed with Milton
Friedman on but I grid Milton Friedman I
think he argues decisively that the
corporation or its management cannot be
held in their roles as corporation or
agents of the corporation for making
normative choices beyond those that
impact its future profitability
corporations might well follow the
notion of enlightened self-interest
which is reducible to a good PR campaign
and and it may in fact that PR campaign
result ultimately in prox profit
maximizing outcomes however I don't
think we can ask the agent of a
corporation owned by diverse group of
owners who have only one objective in
common that is a desire to make profits
to fill the UNICEF envelope on behalf of
its owners each owner can make the
choice of their dividends or capital
gains it's really hard for me to agree
with Milton Friedman but in this case I
think he's you know it's it's not a very
controversial conclusion let me just
finish by saying that the reason I
thought it would be helpful to read the
Greenspan testimony especially
bracketing Milton Friedman is that while
I think the notion of corporate social
responsibility is mushy and of little
value I think Greenspan's in Greenspan's
testimony is a complete indictment of
the world view held by many economists
and especially Republicans who rely on
markets is the ultimate source of wisdom
that that that mythological you know
invisible hand is is is pretty
discredited these days and hopefully
decisively discredit miroslav and I have
agreed to help Dunning
with his notion of responsible global
capitalism by saying that we agree and
he agrees with Greenspan's admission the
invisible hand is neither perfect
omniscient around me powerful so I'm
past my time that that miroslav gave me
but let me just tell you the six things
that I learned by reading all the things
that you've read and some of the things
that i read in addition one making these
choices are really hard to enlightened
self-interest is of no help three
vesting authority and responsibility in
corporations is nonsensical for as green
pant greenspan finally admitted free
markets need regulation 45 the locus of
normative choices is the individual or
governments which rely for their
legitimacy on alignment with the values
of the individuals they represent and
six as Dunning says other institutions
have an important role in developing a
more moral global environment and
educating individuals on making
normative decisions sounds great team
you know the only real challenge the two
issued was about this pyramid of values
and I'll let it let the pyramid of
values pass I think I can happily agree
with good gist of what can t saying and
still think that the pyramid of values
of dunning is a useful thing for what he
is trying to achieve that's going to be
a conversation that you and I'm could
have possibly have for another occasion
and I think the time is now probably
right for us to give Christine better
flora Joel do you want to introduce
christine tim tim has been already in
the class he I think needed no
introduction here in that sense of the
class so but I think it would be useful
and helpful if Christine were to be
properly introduced so um so Christine I
met first because she's a school of
management alum
and and she's been on the board of SMA a
but but but she's you know her her role
and I mean she really isn't a lot of
ways you know kind of the embodiment of
what we talked about at the school of
management we talked about educating
leaders for business and society in this
role that she has played at BP since
2004 and I you know I've had the
opportunity to visit with Christine at
BP and and talked to her over the years
and and she's she's had to give a lot of
thinking very hard thinking about how a
corporation that due to the activity it
does and where it does that activity has
to face a lot of these very complex
moral questions every day and and so
it's why just by itself while why I'm
thrilled she could be here but but she's
also while she's doing that she's also
been working with John Ruggie who's been
the UN Special Representative on
business and human rights and has been
working with him to develop that the the
normative framework for thinking about
rights that the UN essentially wants to
put its seal of approval on so and you
know and then she does a whole bunch of
other stuff but but well but you know
but she's got two jobs so that's there
you go that's Christine she's a great
person too oh you've been defined what I
maybe I shouldn't say anything okay
thanks everybody hi what I'm going to do
then given the way that this
conversation is set up I'm going to just
walk through what I've done since
leaving som and in doing that hopefully
touch upon a lot of these issues of
implementation and of frameworks and
then we can get into it however you want
to get into it so I had done five years
of nonprofit and government work between
undergrad and coming to som joined VP
for a summer internship in 1999 and in
headquarters in London and then joined
full time after graduation and went
right out to Indonesia and I was
supposed to be splitting my time using
my new hard-nosed MBA skills and doing
commercial analysis this was not long
after BP had taken over our co so BP was
reviewing a lot of our co's assets and
Indonesia trying to decide you know what
to spin off what to sell what to keep
what to do with it all so that was
supposed to be by primary role but they
said listen because of some of this
other NGO and government stuff you've
done maybe you can help out with the
social and environmental review around
this one project in particular a
liquefied natural gas plant that we're
building in West Papua because there
seemed to be some issues there that we
need a little bit more attention paid to
so I started doing that and that ended
up being my full-time job and then my
knees and really my calling frankly
because this plant so it's in West Papua
which is quite remote there's a bay
there and there's a very large gas field
and so this project would extract the
gas would be a short subsea pipeline
built to an onshore processing plant and
this would compress the gas freeze it so
that it could be loaded up on tankers
and shipped out to whoever bought it so
this project technically it was very
straightforward bp's built lng plants
all over the world but never in a place
like this so this project had every
environmental and social tripwire for
disaster so it was in the world's one of
the world's largest intact mangrove
forests which meant that it was really
swampy so one of the few places where
you could build a two billion dollar
plant was a little bit above water level
solid ground which meant that it was
also one of the few places in the area
where was feasible to live so there was
a village there of about 150 families
which the Indonesian government said
this is you know what's what's the big
deal we'll just move them so BP was then
getting caught into this resettlement
issue as well by national law the
Indonesian military would be protecting
the project the Indonesian military is
not known for their good community
relations so BP would be stuck in the
middle of that so anyway so what on
earth would we do right so we
commissioned a bunch of impact
assessments and I could talk about this
in great detail but point being that
we had to kind of start from scratch
there was no framework for the company I
mean we had these values and we support
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights but we didn't really know how to
put that into practice so we did lots of
impact assessments brought in lots of
external experts to advise us at an
international level a national level
local level really anybody who would
work with us and came up with a kind of
development plan in collaboration with
some of the local communities and so my
job there was to you know hire people
who would serve as our community
liaisons to again Commission lots of
these studies and establish partnerships
with organizations so we've done some
really innovative work there but it's a
long-term effort the project's going to
be there for at least 30 or 40 years and
the outcomes are not within the
company's control but we've done again
we've tried to be proactive and creative
and only time will tell so from there I
moved to China and I did similar work
around a joint venture a 50-50 joint
venture that BP has with sinopec which
is one of china's state energy companies
and we're building a chemicals plant on
the outskirts of Shanghai municipality
which gets quite rural so it was a town
of about 30,000 people and the workforce
would peak at about 40,000 migrant
workers men from other parts of the
country so it might be some issues there
so again I was to do a social impact
assessment to help ensure that there are
adequate standards health and safety
standards for the dormitories for the
workers but again there was no real
framework or guidance for how to do this
again we're kind of creating it they're
based on the needs of that particular
project so from there I moved to London
and after a year doing some more
commercial analyst stuff so that you
know I didn't forget how to use XL but
anyway I rejoined our group vice
president for strategy and policy
development and after a few months
working for him he asked me to focus on
human rights and he admittedly didn't
know what that meant but there seemed to
be a lot going on with respect to
business and human rights so a number of
our projects in difficult places were
ramping up at the same time so the
project I was on in Indonesia was
finally starting major construction we
had a big similar project in
gola which was starting major
construction we were starting to see a
first oil pop out of this pipeline that
we were building across azerbaijan
turkey and georgia and all these
projects rightly we're attracting the
attention of human rights groups and
then so those that was sort of some
internal factors and externally there
seemed to be a lot going on about
business and human rights so there was a
debate over this proposed set of
standards going on at the UN which I'll
talk about in a second our industry
association had set up a human rights
task force there was something called
the business leaders initiative on Human
Rights which was picking up steam there
so they seem to be a lot going on so we
said basically go figure out what's
going on figure out if we need to be
doing anything differently so i spent
about nine months having lots of
conversations with our staff internally
in different parts of the world getting
up to speed on the external debate and
it didn't start out as you know produce
a policy but actually what people were
crying out for was a framework they said
you know we're trying to invent all
these bespoke solutions but we don't
have any guidance we don't know how to
do this we don't know where to start so
so that's what I helped produce I led
the development of a human rights
guidance note for the company which
basically said okay Human Rights there's
a lot of debate going on it can mean a
lot of different things to a lot of
different people but for BP we can
categorize the human rights that we
impact the most into three categories
into employee issues so looking at labor
rights into security issues and that's
all about bp's relationship with both
private and public security forces
because that's such an important issue
around extractive projects and then
looking at local community issues sort
of all of our kind of good neighbor
issues and how we impact the lives of
people near our projects and again that
that helped a lot because it didn't give
people the answers but it gave people a
way to kind of manage and consider these
issues so while I was doing that I got
to know this guy John Ruggie and it was
during the first year of a three-year
assignment that he'd been given by the
UN his assignment came out of a debate
over this proposed set of standards they
had a very long name there were the
draft norms and I can't remember the
full name the draft norms on the
responsibilities of transnational
corporations and other business
enterprises with respect to human rights
whoo so a committee drafted this
proposed set of standards and they were
very helpful in that they spelled out
topics that companies should pay
attention to so you should pay attention
to labor rights you should pay attention
to environmental protection to consumer
protection but they had a fundamental
flaw and that was that the preamble Earl
anguish said corporations because they
are now so big and powerful they should
have all of the same responsibilities as
governments to protect respect promote
and fulfill human rights so this draft
was put out for consultation and you can
imagine what happened so some
campaigning NGO said this is fantastic
this should be law a lot of business
lobbying group said over my dead body
are we going to assume responsibility
for all these rights the government sort
of saw this debate and said I'm staying
out of this I don't know what to do with
this so when the Human Rights Council
voted on this proposed set of standards
they voted it down they said clearly
these things aren't going to work but
clearly there are issues here that need
to explore that we need to explore and
increasingly human rights abuses are
being linked with corporate activity so
clearly we need to figure out what's
going on so that's where John rugby's
appointment came out of his mandate has
been specifically to clarify standards
of corporate responsibility with respect
to human rights including the role of
governments so it's been a three-year
mandate so far and he's done it with so
much kind of outreach and consultation
that what he is doing is both reflecting
what is out there in terms of
expectations of corporate responsibility
but trying to kind of put it all in one
place and in fact in fact in effect set
a normative framework so the bit of my
story is that when I was doing this you
know I I just finished the the guidance
note the Human Rights guidance note for
BP and I was trying to figure out what
my next BP job should be and saw that
the sky was doing this mandate and the
UN doesn't give anybody any resources to
do these things so I saw that he needed
some help and I know BP does these
executive loans once in a while so I
wrote to John Ruggie first and this was
right after he put out his first report
and it was very clear that he was going
to be interested in what works so he
didn't want to drown
to another international treaty those
can be helpful but it's a 20 or 30 year
process often to negotiate something
that would then have to be ratified by
national governments he's interested in
the spectrum of things that are actually
going to work there's not one single
tool that's going to solve the problem
of corporate related human rights abuses
but what you know what's going to make a
difference to people on the ground so
anyway I arranged a secondo man I'm on
loan to him from BP so so in three years
of doing all this sort of research and
consultation he has produced essentially
a framework for business and human
rights because nobody was agreeing kind
of the fundamental principles you know
as companies were saying human rights
that has nothing to do with me and NGOs
were saying of course it does it has
everything to do with you so he's put
forward this framework and the framework
rests on three pillars they are protect
respect and remedy that's meant to be
the framework for business and human
rights so protect is all about the state
duty to protect so obviously
government's duty to protect people
against human rights abuses it's
fundamental to the whole human rights
system but the point is that it hasn't
been applied rigorously or consistently
to corporations so states need to
fulfill their duties the second pillar
is the corporate responsibility to
respect human rights and so this is to
say that at minimum clearly society
expects companies to do no harm we
expect companies to respect human rights
this is to move everybody beyond that
existential sort of companies have
nothing to do with human rights okay at
minimum do no harm so the question then
becomes okay what do you what do
companies have to do to the to prove to
themselves to prove the satisfaction of
themselves and their stakeholders that
they are indeed fulfilling this
responsibility so I'll get back to that
one in a second the third pillar is
about remedy this is about the people
need greater access to remedy if they
feel like they've been harmed by
corporate activity because right now you
know if you feel like you've been hurt
by a corporation what can you do right
you can try to sue but if you're you
know living in an African country and
you're trying to sue the African
subsidiary of a company with
headquarters in Europe and listed on the
New York Stock Exchange what one on
earth you're going to do and that's
so then it's complicated and are you
going to get any justice you can try to
start a boycott but again complicated
and if you've actually been hurt is that
going to redress harm so this pillar of
the framework just says okay well
there's a spectrum of grievance
mechanisms from the factory and the
project level all the way up to you know
the International Finance Corporation
has an ombudsman whose job it is to
investigate complaints of people
affected by ifc funded projects so
anyway so that's the framework the Human
Rights Council welcomed the framework in
June and it renewed his mandate for
another three years specifically asking
him to develop practical recommendations
within each of the three pillars so
again this question of okay now we've
got this framework and that's great but
now what do we do we need guidance so
the bit that I'm going to be focusing on
is developing a set of guiding
principles for the corporate
responsibility to respect human rights
so what are the 10 or 20 or whatever it
is things that every company needs to do
and again obviously the challenge is to
make it practical enough that you know
companies can actually do something with
it but generic enough this is supposed
to be you know global standard that cuts
across all sorts of sectors so that's
the that's the task and again whatever
he comes out with and whatever we come
out within a couple of years this
doesn't have the force of law but again
he's done it with so much outreach and
engagement in getting submissions from
all parts of the world and having these
meetings in all parts of the world that
again it reflects what is out there and
so hopefully it carries that weight so
let me try to tie what what Tim said to
what you're working on i mean the the
project at some level is agnostic about
the mechanism by which these principles
would become lived I mean it could be
that it's up to States to start putting
in place laws that actually make sure
that these are somehow adhere to it
could be that it's NGOs driving boycotts
it could be that it is
is individuals who are in positions of
power in corporations who even though it
is not necessarily their fiduciary
responsibility to their shareholders
still want to try to lead in a way that
they adhere to these standards and at
the same time have a set of shareholders
who won't question the fact that they're
they're doing everything they can to
that's right i mean you will point to
some specific places where the framework
can be enacted and but i think you're
right that is agnostic about I mean he's
not going to create anything or suggest
the creation of one particular thing or
or say this is the implementation of the
corporate social responsibility movement
right that we now look to corporations
to read this and this is somehow a
reflection of what they must they must
be team how would you respond to the
framework and what it's trying to
achieve from the perspective that you
have sketched for us I don't I'm much
right that much right now I mean I I
think i'm not sure i know i think i
think there is there's a great benefit
in having a dialogue about about
responsibilities and about values and
about you know moral conditions and so
in that respect i think it's it's it's
really great to have that discussion
that debate but you know i think the
world's in such a bad place and I'm much
more anxious to get the Chinese to quit
army in the jajja we'd you know or to
get companies and financial services you
know institutions that quit stealing for
poor people so I just I think that's
great and at some level that's what you
know you do here and you're educating
all these students to go out and have a
moral compass and have a framework for
thinking about how you get these
problems done but for me it's it's it's
either at sort of that level
or it's let's take on the most pressing
problems you know in the world and
figure out how you get them done how do
you get greenhouse gases you know from
destroying the future how do you stop
cigarette companies from selling
cigarettes to people that are in the
third world and ignorant about the
consequences you know that it's sort of
hard for me can I use the same question
to Christine a kind of directly to
respond if you can to what kind of tim
has sketched out in particular the the
aspect of it that corporation qua
corporation does not have moral
responsibility how does that fit with
what you have been sketching and then
we'll open it up to to everybody I just
wanted to get the two of them partly in
conversation with one another and just
to see whether whether there are it all
it's completely with one another their
overlaps how does it exactly look and
then we'll open it up okay yeah i don't
i don't think i don't think we're at
odds at all i mean i would agree that
the notion of corporate social
responsibility it's it has become quite
ill defined and it has come to include
everything from you know philanthropy to
supply chain compliance so i think i
think that it's difficult and i agree
that it's not not not a helpful basis
for dialogue and for progress and i also
agree that what we should be focusing on
is you know what are the problems that
are impacting people's lives on the
ground and what I am concerned with is
how corporate activity actually does
that people are currently being hurt by
business and how do we fix that and it's
difficult but I wouldn't agree with the
notion of entirely separating the
morality of people and of corporations I
mean I understand I understand where
that comes from and I understand that
kind of technically and legally there is
a separation but I don't think people
check their morality when they come into
work I don't think that they should I
don't think anybody wants to and I also
believe that society has an expectation
again of corporations to do no harm of
course
we expect you know people to do no harm
and we know people were companies and we
expect that they are not going to carry
out their jobs in ways that hurt people
so so that's what we're talking about so
I I think in some ways we're in violent
agreement and it's just how are we
framing this conversation and and and to
what extent it does make sense to
separate the individual from the class I
just one I mean I I think we are a
little bit of disagreement cuz I don't
think we can expect anything of
corporations we can spare a lot of
governments we can expect a lot of
churches and synagogues we can expect a
lot of individuals and I think your case
which I I would have liked to read your
research I think is a classic example
Phil Knight look the other way you know
as an individual who was a large
shareholder while they did you know
terrible things in their supply chain
and the only reason that he stopped is
because it was an outrage and because he
was being vilified and his employees
were saying as individuals screw this
i'm out of here and people weren't
buying his shoes and for me talk about
the corporation and you know is mushy
let's go out and find out anybody that's
doing bad stuff and boycott their stuff
and pass laws and get their employees to
quit and then they'll stop doing it